you've got two choices quality or
quantity what would you like we've got
quality of life you've got everything
you need
we're all gonna die sometime and I want
to take as much tech while I'm Miami I
want to enjoy myself as much as I can
[Music]
st. Luke's Hospital Sheffield has been
treating the terminally ill for 45 years
no one here will be cured this is far
more than a place where people come to
die we spent a week at st. Luke's
talking to staff patients and their
families as they confront the end of
life every day starts like this a
meeting of nurses doctors and
consultants who treat the majority of
st. Luke's 1,500 patients in their own
homes the community team liaises with
GPS and hospitals prioritizing those
most in need get a visit from the rapid
response team Connor is a palliative
care nurse just a really nice feeling to
know that you can support someone even
the boss obviously it's a terrible time
for them I think people were a
frightened of death I think that we all
know it's coming to us it's one of the
only certain things in life I don't
think it's something that would tend to
think about very large we went with him
to visit Jean night
she's gravely ill with cancer but
determined to remain at home with
husband Richard hi Jane I'm good thank
you
the last fumes since Christmas I've gone
down you know I mean but it's just it's
come back everywhere Brackley riddle
didn't really it's in me brilliant it's
in me born it's inspiring it's
everywhere you know anyway so it's just
something that you learn to live with
you make that sound you say that like
people talk about having a headache
that's it how did you say that positive
you have to because if you don't you
lose you lose your quality of life
that's what you're here for
you've got two choices quality or
quantity what would you like
quality' you know what I mean if you've
got quality of life you've got
everything you need
it's genes primary carer the hospital
supports Richard - after being sent
lobes or I can talk to a doctor while I
can talk to a nurse and they will sort
you they're condemning our pharmacy and
young to deliver their medication or
allow me to go and pick a lot these
times when I kind of really bad there's
nothing call come on gene now you know
pull yourself together
because if you don't even know go down
so I've pulled myself together and
that's how you got a bike you know what
I mean
positivity that's always at the top
positivity you have to stay like that so
if you don't back at st. Luke's
Judith Park showed us around the
inpatient ward I think you know people
tend to think when patients come into
the impatient Center in Hospice they're
coming in to die they're not about
thirty five percent of our patients are
discharged home but they all have a
terminal illness
so this is our spy room there's even a
whirlpool bath that comes complete with
a light show a small luxury and a way
for patients living with illness to
relax we are scared as a society I think
we are starting to shift slowly I think
there's a big public health message
around death and dying because actually
you know again back to the lady who's
pregnant she gets a bounty pack that's
standard and has been for years in this
country we don't get people a death pack
telling them these are the things you
need to think about and this is what is
really important at some point in your
life
clive Smith the former royal engineer
with cancer was admitted to st. Luke's
more than once but they didn't just
treat him they supported his family two
daughter Julie was so impressed after
his first admission last year she
applied for a job and joined the
housekeeping team and clients
granddaughter Lauren he's in a
bereavement support group recommended by
the hospice it's like and I can just do
whatever I want you can express your
feelings by doing art and they just help
you if you're willing to talk to and
they're continuing a room talk to you
and then look like whatever stays in
that room it doesn't come back home when
you come here obviously they're here
first and foremost for that patient but
then once they're in here you realize
that they're not they they help mom dad
Nana and granddad they're this there is
something there for you a few days after
this Clive died at st. Luke's surrounded
by his family most patients first come
to st. Luke's long before their
conditions deteriorate the day center
provides physical and creative therapy
advice and sometimes just company for
patients dealing with terminal diagnosis
you first heard the words Saint Luke's
or Hospice that's coming out feet I'm
going in and I'm coming out in a box
he's not like that so it's a better than
a hotel
Pamela Walker as cancer has been coming
since she was told she had 18 months to
live that was three years ago well I
mean I want to enjoy myself as much as I
can because if you sit here and think oh
good tomorrow
I've got to plan this I don't want that
sorted I said to me Barry laughs I'm
done that's all done we know and just in
just gonna enjoy myself
one of st. Luke's secrets is in the
kitchen this is no ordinary hospital
food individual leak and smoke how it
starts with that server champ mash or
poached egg chef Nick Wilks runs it like
a restaurant adapting meals to meet the
demands of patients for whom eating may
be one of the last pleasures remaining
so we bake we put my funky powders and
like kind of reform sandwiches and
scones and cakes but the soft but they
don't look they look like a cake but
they can taste like one but they're soft
so they could swallow them yeah yeah
that's where the last thing like we're
like the Willy Wonka's of AHA that's
what we tried to be a thing for the very
ill like Julie Drake Lee the small
things can make a huge difference that's
done she has motor neurone disease and
needs round-the-clock care becomes the
st. Luke's once a month to use the bath
I've got a condition
I'm never going to speak baby better
frob I loved over 70 years with siblings
things we realize it's also helped her
come to terms with how she wants to die
thoughts if they get a traditional
hospital but special sorts of debated
salutes with the beautiful room with
beautiful surroundings with people who
sports you put people who would be to
our holistic suite who have side Bobby
feels totally different this book in the
chapel lists the names of every st.
Luke's patient who's died day by day
it's a poignant reminder of the reality
of the work that is done here and at
more than 200 hospices across the UK
that between them treat more than two
hundred thousand people that is just
forty percent of those who would benefit
from some kind of expert end-of-life
care with an aging population demand for
hospice services is growing fast but
funding is not st. Luke's is a charity
and with just 25 percent of its budget
coming from the NHS it has to raise six
million pounds every year from shops and
public donations on average just 30
percent of hospice funding comes from
the NHS and last year two-thirds of that
was cut for frozen
st. Luke's chief executive believes more
reliable funding could help hospices
ease the pressure on the NHS by caring
for more people currently dying in
hospitals if you took a poll across all
of my my peers across the country and
their teams there will be a consensus
that yes we would like to see better
funding for hot Naches hospice care but
palliative care in general we are after
a more level playing field for what
would be seen as being essential
services in our city and without those I
think the whole of the health care
sector in Sheffield will be worse off
and struggle hospices help patients who
no longer have hope of a cure and
families facing up to loss by doing lots
of little things well take this garden
it's designed so that a patient in a bed
can be wheeled around and it's by doing
things like that offering an hour in the
Sun a favorite meal to someone who
perhaps can barely eat or providing
staff who can answer the hardest of
questions that they restore dignity and
humanity to death Jean Knight's family
is just one of those who have benefited
a month after we went to see her we were
told she had died the end-of-life was
she was just as you wanted and we all
wanted to hear because as I said I daddy
wanted to be in hospital
these auspices and things like that they
are fantastic places but you can't be
being at all and having all your family
around it could have been any better the
other you know the NHS is supposed to
carry us from cradle to grave but it is
often hospices like st. Luke's that help
complete the journey if more of us have
to benefit from their unique expertise
and have a chance at a good death
hospices may need to rely on more in
charity hook ups have Sky News